alright great so I'm going to be talking
about pseudo-random generators for small
space via free analysis and this is
based on some joint work with on their
own gold seville begun and andrew 1 i'm
sure sit around and generators need no
introduction to this audience but
nonetheless the task of a pseudo-random
generators to take a small seed ideally
of length log in and stretch it to
something of length in and this should
be indistinguishable from being true
uniform to all efficient computations or
some class that with the specified that
we wanted for now one particular goal we
might have for constructing sit around
and generators as d randomization so
that means taking randomized algorithms
and turning them into deterministic
algorithms without destroying the
efficiency now if you look at the
landscape of this there's a pie in the
sky goal of the randomizing VPP it's on
that we think is a little bit out of
reach at the moment the firm that sort
of closer to the horizon is the
randomizing instead of polynomial time
logarithmic space and the reason we
think that is approachable is that we
already know how to do randomized
logarithmic space computations into wall
to the 1.5 space and all said this
wonderful d randomization of undirected
st connectivity these are things you
already have
let's talk about the randomizing walk
space so to do this it would suffice to
have a pseudo-random generator that
itself runs and logarithmic space this
is a distinguishable from uniform for
log space distinguishes and has
logarithmic seed lamps those are the
three requirements and the best we have
unfortunately is log squared seedlings
which is enough to show that you have
log to the log squared deterministic
space also have some other d
randomization results which are strictly
pseudo-random generator to
randomizations first as log 2 1.5 Spacey
randomization by sex and Joel and we
also have under edges EXT connectivity
in large space and that's result by on
their angle
so after over two decades we're still
really don't have any improvement in
terms of pseudo-random generators for
log space except for a handful of
special case what we just sort of show
you the cartoon of what Nissan the
approach is just in one slide so
basically you look at your computation
you split it into the first half and the
second half and you say well look the
only sort of communication between these
two is some exit state as opposed I feed
another to truly random bits for the
first part of the computation and I sort
of running low on r and enough so I
wonder what I need to do and i look at
the sudden they say well to still have a
lot of entropy lip because there's only
in assets data that has been remembered
about this these resulting to recycle
this that's randomness now there's
recycling is going to be something like
an extractor a universal hash function
or an expander grass Amy's a little bit
of a jewelry randomness to make this
work
okay great so you know apply this
recursively is what gets you this log
squared seedlings so this approach is
being sort of the basis of decades of
work but somehow it doesn't seem like
we're going to get past this log squared
barrier in the general case because
somehow would have to either get a boy
doing the recursion or get away with a
constant amount of randomness at each
step of the recursion so it sort of
seems like we're a little bit stuck here
we sort of want to bring in some new
techniques so one place that we might
want to look for techniques is a free
analysis so there have been a lot of
success in building pseudo-random
generators that you know their analysis
is built on that free analysis and this
is being successful for other classes of
distinguishes not my personal space
necessarily but for for other things so
let me give you some examples it's very
incomplete list so we know that for
space one bit we can actually get
logarithmic seedlings and that's using
most a small biased distribution which
are very nice tool we also know how to
fool our GF 2 polynomials using the
thumb small box distribution that's
something that Raghu spoke about at the
opening workshop and it gives you you
know a laura sexy length plus some large
terms of the degree
we also know that our half spaces can be
fooled by K wise independence and
similarly we can get a t0 circuits being
full by chaos in the pits now these are
not the best known results we can we can
do better than this but I just wanted to
give you some examples of the success of
using free analytic techniques to
construct pseudo-random generator okay
so why are we talking about today is
trying to construct suitor I'm
generators for small space using
techniques from free analysis now
there's another words that I'm not going
to be talking about but basically that's
the thing i want to push sean is that
and one source of new ideas to help us
develop pseudo-random generators for
small space is the work on free
analytics free analysis based to random
generator
so for the rest of the talk i'm going to
start by introducing the computational
model which is read once branching
programs so this is a model that sort of
catch your small space with a hole so
non-uniform to make it a little more
interesting and i'm going to just
briefly talk about free analysis and how
we can use that sort of measure the
complexity of functions then i'll tell
you about the super random generator
that I'm secure I've been looking at
let's talk about branching programs as a
model of computation so if I tell you
small space and I really think about
extremely small space the constant space
you're going to think hey I'm going to
use a finite automaton so this is sort
of like a uniform model of computation
you've got one thing that doesn't change
depending on the input land the
branching program is just a non-uniform
version of this so think of it as saying
that the transition function changes at
each step three thing of this now since
of acyclic graph and if you get an input
that's going to basically tell you how
to walk through this graph so you start
at some start node and then you just
follow the the edges based on the labels
given to your new input and you lather
end up in an accept motor original so
reasonably easily clean model of
computation and you know you can get
different different inputs that Lola
lead you to outcome and if you sit down
this example that I've put up here is
computing the following DNA
ok so just sometimes the lens which will
demote and is this the number of bits of
the thing reads the width is the number
of states that you have so it's two to
the amount of space let's say you should
think of it and then one distinction
also want to make is between ordered and
unordered branching programs so an older
branching program reads the bits in the
order that they're presented so that one
bit to the three whereas non over
branching program gets to choose how it
reads a bit we're going to stick to read
once watching programs which means that
each bit is only going to be a red line
ok great so I'm sure many of you are
quite familiar free analysis but yes I'm
Mordred case what is going to believe it
this is what is decided in the box yet
so it's not like a dynamic thing where I
get to choose how to read so free
analysis if you're prg does not move the
orders yes otherwise you know you can
just yes so free analysis is this
magical unitary transformation that just
say is take some function represented in
the basis of parity functions and you
know somehow these coefficients these
three coefficients are going to be
really useful and it's kind of magical
to be honest so one way that we can use
you know the Fourier transform is to
sort of measure the complexity of a
function so one simple measure is the
free a mass of a function so you just
take the l1 norm of all of the Fourier
coefficients and it's going to give you
some notion of the complexity of the
function now it's really nice is that if
this is small then we have pseudo-random
generators for them very clean
pseudo-random generators which is the
small biased generator
so I'm going to be talking about a more
refined notion of complexity which i'm
going to call free growth so what you do
is you look not of the whole Prius extra
menu just look at a certain level of the
hypercube you look at the l1 norm of all
the free coefficients at that level so
it's going to give you a more refined
measure the complexity of function and
particular we're going to look at how
this grows with kit I'm going to look at
bounds on the forms you know you start
with some sort of base and they have an
exponential growth be with k
yes especially this name is looking at a
noisy version for function right where
you're flying into noisy and was exactly
yeah so another way you could sort of
measure this is to say and then a sort
of molten your thumb up all the free
coverage is going to multiply them by
some beta to the power of the size of
this sort of damped version of that yeah
I mean damn thing is 48
that if you do the you do the like noise
operator that's just going to multiply
all the coefficients by some some
damping factor and if you look at the l1
norm of the the noise function
equivalent of it okay so now you know
the question is does this actually
correspond to a pseudo-random generator
and the answer is sometimes or well yes
so let's assume we have some class of
functions and you know we have to assume
these are computed by polynomial it's
branching programs and that this class
is closed on a restriction so if I say
it one of the bits of the function it's
still going to be in the class and
suppose I have some nice 3e growth down
for all of the functions in this class
then there is actually then there's
going to be a third random generator
with with this seedling so the seedling
so depends linearly and B which is the
base of the growth of the free a mass
and then you get a log squared enter
no constructively both of you expect but
what was the vegetable long
constructively i mean- audibly words we
get login for just about anything so
what was the drive a meter captions look
like so could you could put in these plz
all games a and B or so you notice that
i have this assumption here this classes
of polynomial with branching programs
and that assumption is important so I
don't know what to do if you remove
those assumptions okay way we said oh
yeah I have two assumptions about it
so now to make this serum you totally
accepted give some examples of classes
of functions that have 938 right now so
to a couple of examples of first of all
regular and branching programs now I
don't want to go into the details of
what means for a branching programs your
regular basically means that if you lose
I'm you know the graph is a regular
graph you also know that for constant
depth polynomial size circuit so AC 0 we
have bounced like this animals heads us
for arbitrary read once branching
programs of which three so these are
some interesting examples that sort of
show that we have downs like this so let
me give a little bit more detail about
this so let's take a regular branching
program then we get a free earth damage
has a base just in terms of the width
and I think this is an interesting down
because it's independent of and so
somehow the free growth doesn't depend
on the number of bits you read and this
gets you a sort of a log squared
seedlings for a permutation branching
programs for AC 0 we get a logarithmic
basically logarithmic base which means
you get a seed seed lances log to the to
the deepest month but this is only for
read once AC 0 because because of the
assumption that you know it has to be
computed by read once branching program
even though the free growth down hold
for non read one station 0
and for with three we get also a long
birthing base plus some polynomial
factor of the front that we don't really
care too much about but she also gives
you a poly logarithmic c.length for with
three people which for it will break
down because of in a sort of certain
things ah my conjecture is was it still
works for with for it's just we don't
have proof like if you consider the
inner product function will it be
computable in this for with surprising
back at the bank
I thought about that I don't maybe talk
about it offline i think that's
interesting question product with three
I don't think so and it depends how
executive Hitler you know okay the point
where this is useful is that this
applies unordered remind program yeah so
that's at some point I'll get to later
so one of the one of them the nice can I
stacks about this is that it's sort of
order oblivious it doesn't matter if you
permute the output bits of this pseudo
random generator it's still going to
have this property whereas Nissan
generator doesn't have the sprocket it
provably doesn't have this pocket I
guess it's okay for I mean in your
product even make all the funny kill
efficient victim might head over to so
it's not a problem ok I don't know the
free transform than a product off the
top of my head
okay so I want to tell you what the
pseudo-random generator is that is
underlying this so let's take our
computation we think of it as reading in
and bits what we're going to do is I'm
going to sue to randomly select a subset
of those deaths and we're going to set
them using a small bias generator so we
select them and almost Kos independent
manner and we set them to values from a
small box distribution okay great so
notice it one percent of the bed now
repeat so we begin select a sort of
random subset of the bits you in okay
almost care wise independent manner and
then we states i'm using a small bios
space and and we repeat this until we
see it all of the bits that things we
have the generator works now this
generator was originally developed by
Gokul on mecka Reingold trevisan bodom
but remember that correctly and what
they use it for us to develop nearly
optimal pseudo-random generators for
read once CNN and then you know later
paper is just sort of a tweak on the
underlying to the random generator with
a slightly different analysis so what's
the intuition for why this pseudo random
generator might work so let's start by
looking at something I've already
mentioned which is using small biased
generators and using them for functions
with low free men let's take a function
with small free and ass and we'll take
some excellent bias distribution so
what's an excellent bias distribution
well if i look at the expectation of
sort of this inner product and i sort of
raise it you know minus 12 thats of
normalize it that's going to be between
plus and minus x1 so we think of this if
it'll mean we free a coefficient of the
distribution and we say these are small
well now all we do is we look at the
expectation of this function under eggs
compare its uniform and this is a very
nice expression in terms of the the free
a coefficient and then you just apply
you know you triangle inequality and you
see that this is going to be the free
mass times the bias of your distribution
this is nice because we know how to
sample such a distribution with very low
seedlings alright so that's the use of
small by spaces to handle functions with
small free men so what about functions
with small free growth so only you could
do this is you could you know take a
flip side with a function that has small
free a growth and will take a small bite
distribution and says before but now
we're going to take a distribution so a
noise distribution I'm just going to say
it's a product distribution so
independent bets but those bits are
going to be a little bit bias is not
beta buy it now if you look at the furry
coefficient of this distribution which
is ian mooing at this its inner product
these things are going to decay so the
larger the ass the smaller the this
expectation let's sort of going to
intuitively kill all the high order free
coefficients where's the small
biodistribution kill whole coefficient
equal now if you run it on the eighth
floor of the small x space in the noise
distribution again with a very nice
expressions into the free transform and
you know now we can substitute in these
down and if you and if the bias of the
noise is smaller than one over the base
of the free growth then we just get the
same expressions we had before just a
time's the bias of the free ok cool so
we see that taking a small bio space
adding some noise produces pseudo random
distribution functions with small for a
growth is this useful well sort of
because the problem is that this noise
is very high end
so how do we actually make use of that
so the intuition the lease of I I find
intuitive is that the cigarette
generator is sort of saying well okay I
can generate small bias I want i'm going
to do is I'm going to sort of
recursively generate something that
looks like this noise distribution it's
not going to be exactly the smaller
distribution but it can be
indistinguishable from this most
distribution I'm going to sort of
explore them like here now this
intuition doesn't quite match what the
generator is doing and more specifically
the generator says I'm going to
recursively generate a shorter pseudo
random string so maybe point nine nine
and and I'm going to Pat that using
optimal black space which is similar to
this excellent process yes you can think
of is slightly differently saying adding
noise is the same as saying with twice
the probability you're going to make the
noise from those two beta you replace a
bit with a random bit so that's like
your restriction so you say you think of
it as restricting putting the epsilon by
a space in the in the unrestricted barn
and then you recursively need to find
the randomness for the for the
restricted part so if you take a
uniformly random string just insert some
random zeros you're going to get the
sort of noise distribution basically how
the pseudo-random generator works
he represented is a recursive thing or
is earlier a sort of unrolling that as
an odor and making an iterative thing so
this is sort of just trying to give you
some intuition for how the free growth
bound corresponds to some to randomness
properties ability to construct the
ground ginger
alright so this is the theorem that we
proved so as I said you know look if we
had this free growth bound that's going
to allow us to do the random generator
but these other two functions here that
are kind of annoying so the clothes
under restriction that's basically
saying when I recover I stay within this
class that's all that's needed for and
the fact that it's computed by
polynomial with branching programs is so
to say that I don't need to do this
padding sing where I insert random zeros
into my string in a true uniform manner
it suffice is for me to do this in a que
twice in the pan in manner we do you
some property of these polynomial with
the branching programs
now where the seedlings come from so
each step in this is going to use some
logarithmic seedlings because you know
we need to sample a small but a small
bias distribution and almost Carol eyes
in the pendant distribution now no need
to count the number of steps so each
step is going to set a one other be
fraction of the bits where B is the base
of the free a growth so if you do be
steps you're going to set a constant
fraction so now you need to do that
logarithmically many times to fit all of
the bits so we get a total number of B
times log n steps we multiply the number
of steps by the amount of seed needed
per step and you get this feeling well
that's some sort of bag intuition for
where where the salt comes from
the point that i mentioned earlier which
is so the nice pseudonymous property
that we would like is permutation in
darien so great so the form of these
days even if you've got some output of a
pseudo-random generator x 13 x and any /
muta dana should still have the pseudo
randomness property it's like a very
obvious property obviously the uniform
distribution satisfies this but what
sort of the strength thing is that
nissan generate does not have this
property so the tank you can come up
with an example of a think it's a with
five branching program with a specific
instantiation of the hash function being
used in these funds generator that is
able to distinguish these things so if
you permute it carefully you actually
can break and break this so long that's
sort of interesting and what's really
nice about all these techniques that
sort of are based on free analysis like
small by spaces and charism if any
distributions is that they have this
permutation of their aunts property if
it's kara is independent you commute it
okay I is independent small bias you
commute it still small by so you know
this generator is 8 has a mutation
invariance property so this means that
our pseudo random generator works much
up for order branching programs but for
unordered branching programs and in fact
the results that I mentioned for
commutation branching programs and with
three branching programs that gives the
best sealants if you're looking at the
unordered setting particular we're going
to get sort of poly logarithmic
seedlings so log squared for a
permutation case and log cubed for the
with 3k and it's an improvement over nu
square root n which is the base mount
previous result
okay so let's summarize by I sort of
told you initially about nissan
generator which gives you this log
squared feed length the really amazing
rizal really powerful but it's sort of
you know we need some some new
techniques our toolkit is you know we
need some more of things to put in there
and somebody so it shows you that we can
use some tools from free analysis bring
them over to work for small space
distinguish errs in particular the
result that I showed you is that if we
have first downs on the free grow to a
function we're going to get to the
random generator and then one nice
property of this that I do want to
highlight is that these are older
oblivious which means you avoid this the
sweetness of Nissan generator which is
that it breaks if you commute tha that's
a bit all right so so further work so
obviously would like to proofread growth
down for other classes get better seed
length then then what I showed you so
there's it should definitely be rude to
shave at least one log office these
results and of course other techniques
and pseudo-random generators is also
things we want to import I mean one
particular conjecture that I want to
leave you with is that if you have wits
with W branching programs we should
basically be able to extend this down to
get sort of a log 2w minus 2 based on
the free throws there's a couple of
reasons we believe this one it's true
for W equals 2 w equals three and also
in general for k equals 1 we know it's
true for special cases so if your it's
got a branching program that computes an
AC 0 read once formula for that computer
it's a regular branching program then
this whole the notice of like the two
most important classes of examples and
also some like results that are
suggestive that this is a limitation on
the power so that's one specific
conjecture that we could put in for
I would imply poly logarithmic seed
lands for unordered branching programs
of consequence so what's w woodhead
seedlings log to w but it'd be better
than this like you know what the worst
example we knew God you so if used like
the recursive tribe function which is
basically time so for which three the
tribes function is PI the mannequins of
sudden and Autry carefully balanced
makes this time but again we know that
this is true for Fremont formulas so I
that Club so we know that the the Opera
bad also holds for that class thank you
[Applause]
situations provided to remediation
variance just because the Fourier
transform into some of these measures is
more importantly that she'll claiming
Fourier coefficients around same degree
monomial right yes for like this you
know the free a for the free a growth
it's just it's a order in depth it
doesn't matter like all the all the
technicians don't care if you commute a
bit you could sell it for a growth for a
20 mile to function
that's a good question I feel like you
should be able to
30 I mean my conjecture would would
imply this those will show you yeah
because we know AC 0 mod tues computable
in madrid where r you want the ammonia
yeah so it's okay that's of attendance
yeah is actually be a little bit greedy
little yes okay yeah so I mean I would
suspect it also works for general but we
know their works for general a senior oh
but I immediately see why would fail for
a 20 month even if we prove those bounce
it what's your generator which is a
right yeah that's one of them be
interesting in it is right what is the
simplest example of a function you have
majority function is it takes a bit that
function you can put 80 so if you put
equals bali and if they allowed to make
me being into the phone what's the worst
thing that can be there for any function
rude am so fortunate will then the type
for majority the first a majority if you
put a or would equal to poly and a
doesn't really help you want to get up
to log your k being water let's make it
it takes I'm very socially like what you
would say
oh it's what i'm saying is if you would
eat about every week if you allow it to
be very loud chanting a really helps you
that much because you know once you
bring k up to logarithmic it doesn't
like the a in sort of how much of the
mass of the majority function the what's
that l one massive majority of the
production they've got a video to kobes
are like one let me tell to mass is one
and so if coefficients are all about the
same and they're about one square root
through to the end but there are two to
the end of them and because of some of
the l1 poirier club could be as much as
two to be in over 2 that's not home for
this think that this function is ok
right because you have you just might
because Christians benches kids right
and the result that I showed does get
you about square root and seedlings or
majority was like that so it's not
completely
pick one more person familiar with those
properties you will having a plan Regina
business it actually only needs it up to
log and the thing is once you get to log
you can sort of do some bootstrapping
and then it automatically holds for
larger values that's because of the
assumption that is computed by a
polynomial with the French program wait
let's break for lunch and thanks Deepika
[Applause]